country music's biggest stars combined
celebration with solemn remembrances at
the Academy of Country Music Awards
singer Jason Aldean took center stage
last night in Las Vegas the performance
was his first in Las Vegas since gunfire
broke out during his set at a music
festival there more than six months ago
Nancy O'Dell from our partners at
Entertainment Tonight is in Las Vegas
Nancy what an incredible show that was
last night
oh it so was the I mean it was amazing
and Jason Aldean won Entertainer of the
Year for the third year and the row and
yes he said it was very emotional for
him to return to Las Vegas because as
you said he was actually on stage when
the gunfire broke out at that festival
and he said last night it was so good
for him to be surrounded by what he
calls his country family
[Music]
country singer Jason Aldean's has his
first Las Vegas performance since
October shooting was an emotional
homecoming he talked about the tragedy
as he accepted his award for Entertainer
of the Year it's been a rough year and I
just want to say thanks to everybody
that reached out to us that showed us
love and support over the last six
months it meant the world to us he was
still shaky backstage just being back
here I mean it just been an emotional
thing for us the whole weekend and to
sort of end it like that I mean that's
just you know that's crazy
rather than opening the award show with
a song Aldean was joined by fellow
artists including Miranda Lambert to pay
tribute to the lives lost on this night
our country community the people here in
Las Vegas and all of you at home are you
not answered the healing power of music
[Applause]
Lambert won two awards including female
vocalist of the year she now has a
record 32 ACM Awards
but she wasn't nominated for Entertainer
of the Year and neither were any other
women this year I don't understand
what's going on with that but I know
that there's gonna be a change and I
know that as we just keep plowing ahead
it will get recognized
[Applause]
Carrie Underwood delivered one of the
night's most powerful performances her
first public appearance since entering
her face in November which he said
required 40 to 50 stitches she received
an extended standing ovation followed by
an ACM Award for vocal event of the year
I'm still kind of like right now
[Music]
but more than anything Sunday night was
an opportunity for healing many
attending the ceremony or pens
commemorating the 851 injured and the 58
who died in October as the country music
community came together Vega strong Vega
strong you know I also asked Jason
Aldean when he arrived on the carpet I
said you know how did the whole Vegas
tragedy change you as a man and he said
it he felt like it really made him grow
up it really made him think about what
was important in life and also spoke
with Hilary Scott of Lady Antebellum and
she said that they were not going to
live in fear that they were there to
celebrate country music just as those
people were there the festival were
there to do and that's why they wanted
to make last night a celebratory night
and respect all those people who are at
that festival it was so great to see all
those big names Reba Carrie Miranda
adjacent but you could argue that the
biggest winner wasn't there and for good
reason Chris Stapleton won Album of the
year also his birthday and by the way
celebrating the birth of twin boys he
had the best reason of anybody not to be
there and he shouldn't have been there I
mean I think his wife never would have
forgiven him for those little baby boys
but what a great thing that they came on
his birthday you know and that he was
able to help but he wanted walked away
with two awards but I say he's just
winning at life with all that going on
his birthday two awards and twin boys
all night right yeah incredible night
you gave Carrie Underwood really brought
down the house it was so nice to see her
back on stage did you get to talk to her
how she doing you know she is doing
great from what we saw only a
performance and you know her on stage
she just really took the house down in
the standing ovation if you could have
been in that room it was electric I mean
the support that she had and the
standing ovation that she got that just
went on and on and on she didn't do any
red carpet interviews or any interviews
backstage she's been very you know
secretive and not talked a lot about the
accident but I'll tell you what she
really knocked the house down because
everybody was cheering her on and
pulling for her and she did just Anna
Mae
job and of course looked absolutely
beautiful while she was doing it so I
think that took a lot of courage to come
out so just begin such a public way well
Nancy O'Dell always good to see you
thank you so much for joining us